This is the big lie that you have spoken out against for a long time,
or you should feel very vindicated over the past few minutes,
pretty vindicated lately, because the big lie we've always heard is, Oh,
these college campuses, these are just a bunch of idiots.
Just wait until they get out into the real world. Well, uh,
I'm looking around the real world now,
and I'm seeing the consequences of those college campuses.
As the buildings are burning down all around the country.
[Inaudible].
People over the last, you know, five years,
we're yelling at guys like us for talking about what was going on on college
campuses. Oh, it's just a bunch of kids, you know? And it's like,
actually you do know that this is leaking out into society and these people are
graduating and they're starting to take down institutions.
Literally you have young editors at publishing houses that are getting books
canceled at the New York times. And the New York times has been taken up.
Do you think this thing is going to destroy virtually every liberal
institution? So we have.
This is the big lie that you have spoken out against for a long time,
or you should feel very vindicated over the past few minutes,
pretty vindicated lately, because the big lie we've always heard is, Oh,
these college campuses, these are just a bunch of idiots.
Just wait until they get out into the real world. Well, uh,
I'm looking around the real world now,
and I'm seeing the consequences of those college campuses.
As the buildings are burning down all around the country, the,
the issue with the institutions you bring up is a,
is an interesting one because we've been told for the past few weeks
that all of these protests are about institutional racism, right?
But then it occurred to me,
the left controls every major institution in America. Yeah.
Control the media controls, higher education and lower education controls.
Hollywood controls, big tech controls, administrative government control,
basically other than talk radio and some little parts of the internet,
the left controls every institution. So if there's institutional racism,
whose fault is that?
Well, not only whose fault is it,
but they are the ones putting it into the institutions.
They're the ones making it systemic. Harvard.
Harvard says we want less Asian people because you guys have had it too good
through hard work and education. So we're going to Institute a racist policy.
I don't know if you saw it. I just tweeted last night or this morning, uh,
this thing in, in Tacoma, Washington, where they're now go,
it is going to be in practice that if you have lost your job or need
housing, because of COVID,
they're only going to help people who identify as people of color.
You might have something. I might, you know, the Sicilians wiggle room here,
right? I mean, you see that you saw this with Uber eats, right?
Uber eats love this one. They come out. They say,
if you're ordering from a black owned business, whatever that is, I don't know.
How are you going to measure the equity here? A black owned business.
There's no delivery fees, but if it's a white owned business,
there will be delivered. They are the ones actually.
Injecting racism into the system. Of course.
But that's the point. You know, I, it occurred to me.
I thought a friend came up to me the other day said, Michael,
it's almost like they want us to be racist.
They're tr they're the mainstream media, the left,
they're ginning up this racial division. It's like, they want us to be racist.
And I realize they do.
They actually need you to be racist because so much of liberalism
is about overcoming this oppressive past, right?
So the whole story of liberalism is you can't end. It can't end. It's got,
you've always got to be freeing yourself, but look around you.
You remember early on in the riots,
the mainstream media tried to blame white supremacists.
How many Klansmen are there in America? Like four left or something.
But I don't, I didn't see a whole lot of white hoods out there. I saw,
I saw a white hood on the governor of Virginia, the Democrat, Ralph Northam.
I didn't see it in the riots. So they,
they have to either create this boogeyman or actually try to create racists
if only to have a villain to then overcome.
Well, also, when they're going through these cities, destroying everything,
we were talking about West Hollywood,
which is literally the gayest place on earth.
They have rainbow crosswalks, the entire West Hollywood right now, as we tape,
this is boarded up. I used to live there. I went there a couple of days ago.
It is boarded up. It looks like a third world nation. And on every sign outside,
it says, BLM, the implication being don't destroy our business. We're for you.
Black lives matters, but help watch what I can do here.
If it was white supremacists that were rampaging through the neighborhood,
wouldn't you be writing like white power on the side, because then you go, I'm,
I'm a white supremacist. You're a white supremacist.
Don't don't bust up my business.
And also it's worth noting. This is pride month, right?
So I call me grower. I'm not an expert.
I thought this was supposed to be the month to celebrate West Hollywood and the
LGBT community,
but that it progressivism changes so fast that now pride
month is canceled. And now pride month is BLM month.
What's it going to be next year?
You remember a couple of years ago at Toronto pride when they stop BLM
stopped the March and said, you guys can't March any further,
unless you sign our edict or our, whatever it is.
And basically they did.
And they let them March in a bunch of us talked about it and they said, Oh,
here you go again here. When you guys go again, this.
This issue of the, the intersectional politics. It's,
it's an interesting one here because you're almost seeing the return of more of
an old school Marxism. You know, for the past 10 years,
you've been hearing about how the gay community has something in common with the
trans community.
Just kind of ironic because those two communities sort of contradict one
another. Either. There,
there are individual sexes and same-sex attraction is having to do
with the two sexes or there's no such thing as sexes.
And so that contradicts the G and the LGBT, right?
But those have something to do together. You're gonna have Gloria Steinem,
radical feminist holding hands with Linda Sarsour and islamised at the women's
March. And that makes sense. But now you're seeing that,
I think begin to fade away a little bit into more of an old school.
The black lives matter interest is not the LGBT interest and the
BLM one is going to take precedence, even though all of,
all of it comes down to a sort of radical Marxism. And this,
this is the part that I think some of the squishy types don't yet,
because they'll say, they'll say the word black lives matter.
Nobody disagrees with that. Here's my evidence that nobody disagrees with that.
Everybody posted the black square on social media, everybody,
everybody in government, in media, in corporate America, in all your friends,
they all did it. It's no one disagrees with that stuff.
Yeah. Even people that didn't want to do it,
not because they're not for black lives,
but because they don't like being bullied into things, they did it too.
They did it too. But then you look at the black lives matter website,
the about us section, and it's not just about black lives mattering.
At one point, it says we exist to destroy the quote,
Western prescribed nuclear family. What,
uh, what does that have to do with police brutality or it's obviously,
and you can see the founders of BLM come from radical leftist organizations,
which get their funding from the open societies foundation,
which is run by George Soros.
That's that's not a conspiracy theory with nonprofits. It's not,
it's not anti-Semitic to say that. I don't even know how would it be?
We're Soros has lived his life to basically fund every Jew hating
thing. There is pretty much right, right.
He would love to have Israel wiped off the map.
So the idea that saying that George Soros funds these things is antisemitic.
Right? It'd be, it becomes what,
what the left wants to pretend is that this is a racial issue primarily,
and it's not the left uses race all the time, but it's not.
You can see when you look at the about us section of the BLM page,
when you look at who's funding, it it's primarily ideological.
And I think there are some squishy conservatives and Republicans who want to go
along with it because they they're afraid of being called racist,
even when they're not at all racist, but that's a,
that's a very bad deal to get into.
Cause then you're accepting radical leftist premises that are going to undercut
everything you stand for.
In many ways though,
do you think the ship has sailed to the point that we don't
have enough power to fix this thing that,
that you're laying out since and,
and thoughtful analysis and people are waking up to it.
And I do think a ton of red people are being red pilled right now because,
because just reality is red pilling them, right? I've got Hollywood lefties,
friends that are calling me and they're like, where do you get a gun?
So it's like, so something's happening here. But in many ways,
do you think that the destructive force of this thing has,
has so infiltrated everything that nothing can, can return?
You've hit the nail on the head, which is,
we were beginning to see more people than just conservatives or classical
liberals or just normal people are seeing yikes.
Something has gone seriously wrong here.
And yet very little is being done to it. You see,
even the president of the United States, more or less,
all he can do is tweet about it. And people were saying, okay, enough tweeting.
You got to actually do something, but it gets back to the institution's issue.
The left controls, the institutions, which means the left controls,
the levers of power.
The only institution that we've got on the right is talking.
And so we can talk until we're blue in the face.
We can point out hypocrisy until we're blue in the face. And the left says,
yeah, okay. You've pointed out my hypocrisy. I still have the levers of power.
I think what is required now of the Rite and of conservatives is to
take back it actual institutions of power.
And perhaps even more importantly,
to be willing to exercise that political power when we have the ability to.
What does that mean? Rubber meets the road. What are you saying?
Like actually start separate universities. I mean,
there are some more conservative leaning universities and some of them have
thrived in the midst of all this and university of Chicago though. It's not,
it's not conservative per se,
but they have actually instituted like an actual defense of free speech and they
probably won't burn as quickly as the rest of these other places.
But what do you actually mean by that? Like what,
what is the institution building?
So that would be a wonderful thing. I mean,
unfortunately I could probably count the conservative universities on one hand
and they're really great universities, I guess the,
the silver lining and the storm cloud of the coronavirus lockdown and some of
the riots is that you're seeing a collapse in many ways of this decrepit
educational infrastructure that,
that not only does not give people an education and it does not give people an
ability to have a career. And it does saddle them with a lot of debt.
All it does is indoctrinate them in a very modern sort of politics,
which is not worth the cost of admission.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.